well if you plan to shop online after
Christmas watch out for pop-up ads
peddling free trials for everything from
teeth whiteners to skin creams a new
report from the Better Business Bureau
says risk free trials may sound enticing
but are often a scam the bureau says
consumers can be misled with auto-enroll
subscriptions where they get billed
month after month often without ever
knowing Americans have lost close to 1.3
billion dollars in the past decade in
the scams and a Werner is here now with
how to protect yourself and a good
morning that's a lot of money lost
good morning Dana well you know it can
be hard to tell what's a real ad for a
weight loss product or a skin cream and
one that's fake we met one woman outside
Chicago who fell victim to one such ad
with a phony endorsement from a popular
TV show so you thought if shark tank
people are endorsing it it must be a
real seal good debbie wagner decided to
give it a try a skin care cream called
derm eva all she had to do was pay a
minimal charge of around 6 or 7 dollars
for shipping for a free trial but when
she got the product it was like a watery
cream and what was advertised improves
the visible signs of aging did it do
that
no but a month later wagner says another
shipment of the face cream showed up at
her door along with an eye serum from
the same company that she says she never
ordered and she learned she had been
built $89 for the face cream about $70
for the eye serum like $160 a month one
hundred and sixty dollars a month not
bound for how many months four months
and when she called customer service she
says they told her she had signed up for
it did you ever see any disclaimers or
information on the webpage on the ad
that said if you sign up for this you're
gonna have continuing shipments no
buried in fine print she says if she
didn't return the product in 14 days
she'd be getting monthly shipments of a
product she didn't want so how do you
feel about the fact that you wound up
spending over $500 in this fashion I was
surprised how did that happen Wagner is
not alone the
Business Bureau found complaints about
free trials more than doubled between
2015 and 2017 consumers who complained
lost an average of a hundred and eighty
six dollars seventy two percent of them
were females Steve Baker investigates
these scams for the BBB
he says companies rarely give refunds
you've got a tremendous number of people
who think that's just there's not much
risk that it's just a buck or two to try
this thing out and then they find oh my
god I've been conned it's a trap I can't
get out of it I want to share with you
the secret to our incredible weight loss
system and remember those acai berry
dietary supplement ads the Federal Trade
Commission says one of the companies
behind those weight loss pills took at
least eighty million dollars from
consumers through deceptive free trial
subscriptions and the agency said none
of the ingredients used in those bills
would actually cause weight loss some
didn't even contain acai the company was
later shut down by the feds it's a scam
and there are phony celebrity
endorsements recent headlines on fake
websites and social media said Judge
Judy was retiring to set up a skincare
line
she later set the record straight along
with Ellen DeGeneres
if you don't see us with our mouths
moving talking about a product if you
just see a picture of us we're not
endorsing that product as for Wagner
she says she's learned her lesson if I
could scream it from the rooftops I tell
people please please please don't do
free trials well she did get about four
hundred dollars back but only after she
went to the Better Business Bureau and
we tried calling the company that makes
this eye cream she bought it goes to a
customer care number the FTC and the BBB
have some tips on free trials guess what
if you have to enter your credit card
number that's a red flag
also please read the fine print and
check your bank and credit card
statements regularly a lot of people
don't actually notice that they've been
billed until it happens for me yeah
that's a good idea right right today and
take a look yeah take her for stepping
forward with her story it's not easy to
admit that that happened to you
she said she was embarrassed actually
and she was hesitant initially to talk
about it but you know people shouldn't
be embarrassed because they
they're setting up these programs in
certain ways for reasons
it happens all of us it works for a
reason from one scam to another coming
up and I thank you very much we
appreciate it